- [Voiceover] The graph
above in the ta-plane
approximates the Apollo 8's altitude, a,
in kilometers, t seconds after lift-off.
Approximately how many
kilometers per second,
how many kilometers per second
was the Apollo 8 traveling between 156
and 184 seconds after lift-off?
Alright, so let's look at this chart.
They're calling it the
ta-plane because our horizontal
axis is the t-axis measuring time,
our vertical axis is the a-axis measuring
altitude in kilometers.
This is time in seconds,
this is altitude in kilometers.
Now they wanted to
know, well what was the,
how many kilometers per second
was the Apollo 8 traveling between
156 and 184 seconds.
And they labeled those points for us,
this right over here,
this point tell us what was the altitude
of Apollo 8 at 156 seconds,
you see the 156 seconds
right over here.
So our t coordinate I guess you could say
is 156 and this right over here tells us
the altitude at 184
seconds, it's 96 kilometers.
At 156 seconds, it's 70 kilometers,
at 184 seconds, it is 96,
it is 96 kilometers.
So if we wanna find,
if we wanna approximate
how many kilometers per
second was the Apollo 8
traveling between those two points,
well kilometers per
second, we're figuring out
the rate of change of altitude.
And we should really be
talking about kilometers
per second in the vertical,
in the vertical direction,
is I guess what we should
assume if we wanna be
a little bit more precise.
But that would be just the rate of change
in altitude, or the rate
of change in altitude
with respect to time.
But we can approximate that by finding the
slope of the line
between these two points.
So what's the slope of that line?
Well it's gonna be change in altitude
over change, over,
over change in time.
So let's see, change in altitude is going
to be 184 kilometers,
and I can even keep it in
kilometers or write the units down,
make it a little bit clearer,
minus 156 kilometers.
And then our change in time
is going to be 96 seconds
minus 70 seconds.
So what's that going to be?
185 minus 156 is...
that's about 20, let's see, if it was 154
it would be 30, so this is
going to be 28 kilometers.
This is gonna be 28 kilometers,
over, what is this?
26 seconds.
Over 26 seconds.
So this is going to be a little bit more,
so slightly more, so
28, this is going to be
28 over 26 kilometers per second.
So this value right over here, this is
a little bit more than one.
One would be 26 over 26, so this is,
yeah you could view this as one
and two twenty sixths,
or you could write this
as one and one thirteenth.
So a little bit more than
one kilometer per second.
So let's look at the
choices right over here.
Now you look at the choices here
and you, only one of 'em is
a little bit more than one.
This is less than one,
so you rule that out,
this is a lot more than one,
and a lot more than one,
so we would go,
we would go with that one right there.